this is the entire conceit of my
business idea right
i believe 75 to 80 of sports fans
are in no way woke right because sports
is the ultimate meritocracy
if you are the best at what you do you
get paid the most and you are allowed to
excel that's what should happen in
all of american society instead we're
bringing identity politics and cancel
culture to sports and i think
75 80 percent of sports fans don't want
woke sports right they don't want to sit
around and talk about what a hero
caitlyn jenner is
uh and if you're in that group then out
kick is for you
if you're another 20 by the way there's
a knife fight
every day among sports media members to
see who can be the locust
they can have their night knife fight
we're going to serve the other 75 or 80
percent of the sports marketplace
and i think they're going to like what
they find at outkick
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the founder of outkick.com
and truly and i mean this truly one of
the best men
in all of journalism clay travis welcome
back to the reuben report
i appreciate you having me uh i'm
excited to be back on i think the first
time i came on
uh was after that cnn uh implosion
explosion ridiculousness
uh back in 2017 maybe the fall of 2017
and
a lot of what we talked about frankly
the first time i came on your show
has only gotten worse since then into
your credit
you predicted that was going to happen
and i think
it's just become more chaotic clay i
take no pride in it but before we do
anything else for those that have not
seen
the incredible clip of you and brooke
baldwin you
dared dared to say the word boobs
on cnn and you paid the price paint the
picture for the people
so look i mean we know you know that
that much of uh
much of t tv is fundamentally artificial
and so
it's easy to say things like hey i'm a
first amendment absolutist
but the cliche of a statement like that
sort of deadens it on hearing because
it's so transparently cliched and
frankly because so many people who say
it
are the exact opposite you know a first
amendment uh absolutist they don't
absolutely believe in the in the
marketplace of ideas
and so what i started saying on my radio
show years and years ago
was the only two things that have never
let me down
are the first amendment and boobs right
sports talk radios
staples dangerous a lot of men out there
a lot of women as well
uh agree with that statement and so i
would kind of say it as a
tongue-in-cheek way
to advance the first amendment because
that is a little bit of an outlandish
thing to say right
i'm old enough to remember when the hugh
hefners of the world were considered
to be heroes for their willingness the
larry flints of the world
to push the boundaries of acceptable
speech and so
uh in many ways you and i overlap here
i'm much
less troubled by the idea of
disagreement
than i am by the idea of agreement
because agreement is what happens in
totalitarian
governments that's not when everybody
has the same opinion it's not because
they actually have the same opinion it's
because so many people
are afraid of being able to say exactly
what they think so
i just kind of tossed that line out i've
done it for years
and brooke baldwin lost her mind she was
like oh my you know like basically
oh my god she immediately started to
basically demand that i
give an apology and i just leaned into
it uh
and uh and and so doing i think uh
struck a blow for many people out there
that are just so
used to any time somebody says i'm
offended that
you're just going to drop down on your
hands and knees and beg for forgiveness
and frankly
she's an adult i'm an adult what i said
wasn't in any way an offensive
comment and so why would i apologize for
it and she
i think you know began what has become
the ritualized woke demand
for a apology and the fact that i
wouldn't do it
i think even people who didn't
necessarily agree with my phrasing
uh respected the fact that i wasn't
willing to embrace the ritualized
apology which has become such a staple
of modern day
woke culture yeah and subsequently flash
forward three years
you're absolutely blowing up and out
kick is blowing up and you're about to
launch on locals or you just launched on
locals this morning which we're going to
talk about
in just a second and brooke has
apparently retired from cnn so these
these things have a way of working
themselves out but before we do
uh some of what you're launching right
now do you find it sort of bizarre
that you spend so much time talking
about politics and all this stuff
because
partly why outkick is successful is
espn went all in on all of this stuff
and i mean this is what we were talking
about three years ago but
if anything it's gotten worse and now
we're trying to give people some
alternatives
no i think it certainly has gotten worse
and i think sports i know you're an
old-school 1990s nba fan
as many people out there who watched the
last dance
which sort of epitomized that era the
jordan era nba
were and to me what it represents
is using sports as a fulcrum upon which
to attack
a basic american societal values and
create a marketplace
where only one opinion is allowed and it
came to
i think ahead regarding
people not even being willing to go
visit the white house where somehow if
you were going to the white house you
were endorsing everything that the
president of the united states was
saying
all of that was transparently ridiculous
and so
uh i think there is a massive demand out
there
for a marketplace of ideas in the world
of sports and look i think sports and
politics by and large
should be separate arenas because i
think most people go into sports
to escape the serious things in life you
know guys just want to kick their feet
up and girls
and watch a game instead of having to
worry about everything
else that's going on in politics that's
why sports were so popular
historically i believe but even worse
than sports going political
is this idea that you can only believe
that colin kaepernick
is a hero or that steve kerr and greg
popovich
when they were attacking donald trump
were speaking truth to power and deserve
to be lionized for that or lebron james
or megan repino it's a one-way street if
you are a left-wing activist
masquerading in the world of sports you
become
incredibly incredibly praised by the
woke sports media which is even more
liberal and i know this is crazy for a
lot of people to understand
the sports media is even more liberal
than the political media is
i dave this is gonna be crazy to you i
think and i'm still kind of stunned by
it
do you know that in the entire world of
sports
i am the only person to publicly say
that i was voting for donald trump
not one other person with any sort of
substantial audience in the world of
sports media
came out and said hey i'm voting for
donald trump and i laid out exactly why
i was doing that and you would be amazed
or maybe you wouldn't be
by the hundreds of people in my industry
who reached out and said
i am doing the exact same thing thank
you for going public with your vote
i'm terrified i'll get cancelled or i
will lose my job
if i say that i am doing what you are
doing
and that to me is just an example of how
bereft my own industry has become
uh when you consider the larger arena of
sports and how it intersects with
politics right but of course
the irony here is that you then you saw
all this you started talking about it
and then what you do you didn't just
complain about it you started building
your own stuff so can you just talk for
a minute before we get into the local
stuff about how
outkick is blowing up because we're
watching espn
crumble i mean i tweet about it all the
time that i can't watch any of these
things anymore i simply
i can't watch them but you're actually
building something
that's right uh so one of the things
that we're doing is we're building our
own
over-the-top network it will include my
radio show which is on nationwide from
six to nine a.m eastern and by the way
is absolutely exploding we have the
biggest national sports talk radio show
in the country for mornings
across the entire united states which is
a pretty good endorsement of
what i am selling being actually
reflected as being popular among sports
fans
uh but we're going to be live basically
competing with espn programming through
our own outkick over-the-top network
from 6 a.m in the morning on the east
coast until 7 p.m
on the east coast which is the time when
there are typically not
games going on so 13 hours a day the
plan is by the time we get to august to
have 13 full
hours set up by march 15th we will have
seven hours
up and running and basically be creating
our own network now it'll be able to
you'll be able to consume it audio video
as many different ways as possible you
can go to outkick.com i'm sure we're
going to be using uh your site which i
give you tremendous credit for building
uh the on locals community to allow
people to be able to interact with it
we have set up our own vip community uh
where you can sign up and and have
exclusive access to uh to our talent and
to our
events to be able to comment all of
those different things we're over 10 000
subscribers for that
99 for a year we think we're going to
continue to grow that at a rapid rate
and look i believe in capitalism i
believe in the marketplace and instead
of just standing on the sidelines and
complaining
about what other people are doing i want
to fight with them
in the marketplace of ideas and in the
marketplace in general and i think we're
going to win because i believe our ideas
in the world of sports as it intersects
with politics
are better than theirs i think our
people are smarter more original more
authentic and funnier than theirs
and i think that that is what sports
fans are going to respond to in a big
way we've already seen it start to
happen
and i think the future for outkick is
very bright as we continue to add more
and more unique voices to uh to our
universe yeah and i just love it man
because it's like guys like us it's sort
of ironic right like we talk for a
living so you know there's
there's value in talk but one of the
things that i've really shifted on is
like
i can't just sit around and talk all day
i gotta do stuff so that's why i love
that what
everything that you're building without
kick and now you're gonna launch on
local so it's outkick.locals.com and
you're gonna have all the community
features there and people can come
and it will be free of uh the big tech
overlords because even in the world of
sports they're watching you man
no there's no doubt and look what i
believe is there are a lot of people who
just want to have honest conversations
and if you sit there on twitter or
facebook or instagram or wherever
you are thinking about sharing your
opinion and you share the quote-unquote
wrong opinion you are absolutely
lambasted and many people may decide if
you can be tracked down that you should
be canceled
and so i think what we're selling too
many sports fans
is water and they're in the middle of
walking in the desert and they're
going to see us and say oh thank god i
can finally interact with people
who have similar opinions that i do and
also say
exactly what i think about the world of
sports and by the way
it can just be sports right like it's
crazy right frustrated with the fact
that every single thing that happens in
the world of sports
has to happen through an identity
politics prism oh this coach got fired
what was his race is that why oh this
new player
didn't get the contract that they
thought they were oh is that because
they're if
if you're just like man i like to watch
sports and talk about the games that
take place
on the field and the actions that take
place there there's frankly
not a lot of that anymore and so we want
to provide that opportunity for people
you know it's funny i was thinking about
you on the way back from florida the
other day because i'm on american
airlines going through their tv
app where you know you can watch
whatever you want and they have like a
black history
month channel or something so it's all
it's all black producers and black stars
that's perfectly fine
you go all the way to the end of it and
it's got the megan rappano
hbo show and it's like it just shows you
how stupid
intersectionality is she's not black i i
if she was black that would be just fine
too
but that they combine whatever her it's
woke whatever lack of a better way to
describe it
look i believe and this is this is the
entire conceit of my business
idea right i believe 75 to 80
of sports fans are in no way woke right
because sports is the ultimate
meritocracy
if you are the best at what you do you
get paid the most and you are allowed to
excel that's what should happen in all
of american society
instead we're bringing identity politics
and cancel culture to sports and i think
75 80 percent of sports fans don't want
woke sports right they don't want to sit
around and talk about what a hero
caitlyn jenner is
and if you're in that group then outkick
is for you
if you're another 20 by the way there's
a knife fight
every day among sports media members to
see who can be the locust
they can have their night knife fight
we're going to serve the other 75 or 80
percent of the sports marketplace
and i think they're going to like what
they find at outcast let me let me ask
you one other thing before i let you go
uh you know super bowl a couple weeks
ago very few people in the crowd
you know sports are sort of starting
half starting a little bit more in
florida maybe texas
are we ever because as you said i watch
those old nba games and one of the
things i'm starting to notice now when i
watch the games
is there is something truly magical
about being in a crowd with people
whether whether you're rooting for the
home team or you're rooting for the road
team there is something magical about
being around people that shared
experience
you think we're ever going to get back
there or have we just done something
to our collective psychology that half
the country is just going to be afraid
of ever getting out there and rooting
for for teams and people they care about
again
my hope is and my belief is that even
the most woke corona bro as i call them
out there the people that have been
curled up in the fetal position in their
basements for nearly a year now
terrified they're going to die
are going to eventually like groundhogs
peek their heads up look around
and realize that the apocalypse didn't
happen and that many of us
managed to continue to live our lives
without fear you mentioned florida
i think ron desantis has done the best
job of any big state governor in the
country just by being the most
criticized
and i believe states like florida and
texas are going to lead us out of the
sports wilderness
and have full stadiums i really believe
this by around july 4th in major league
baseball
i'm advocating for it already if you
want to go look you just said you took a
flight american airlines flew back from
from florida to l.a i'm hopping on a
flight to mexico tomorrow
dave if i can sit in and they told me
that there's no middle seats open right
it's completely full flight because a
lot of people want to go to mexico where
the weather's perfect and i don't blame
them right now but
if uh if i could sit on an airplane
which is an enclosed metal
tube with recirculating air next to
strangers for hours at a time
how can i not go sit outside at a major
league baseball stadium
in the sunshine and have a hot dog and a
beer and kick up my feet and enjoy a
baseball game
surrounded by other people too we know
covet doesn't pass very much outdoors
if you had to choose which was safer why
is airplane travel
commonplace you're willing to do it i'm
willing to do it but you can't go sit in
a crowded baseball stadium and watch
games
but it's one of the big issues i think
so many people have is kind of the
emperor with no clothes we've been sold
artificial bills of good that have been
labeled science
and they aren't in any way
representative of what real
rational thought would lead us to make
in terms of choices so
i think by july 4th i really do that
finally we're going to win this battle
schools are going to be opening back up
and and i think with the country
ultimately i hope we're going to get
an adequate reckoning on this but i
think as a
society we have made the worst decisions
since the vietnam war
and back then all the experts were the
ones who told us we had to go to war in
vietnam and over the ensuing years and
decades
we found out they were selling a false
bill of goods i think that's what's
happened to us with much of the covet
response
yeah well listen man i i really i'm not
just saying this because you're joining
locals i think what you're doing is the
future of sports journalism i think the
big boys are going down
and you're right 80 of people they care
about what happens
on the field and on the court and and
that's it and that's what you're
bringing
so it's outkick.locals.com to join the
locals community and you'll be
interacting with people and
all sorts of stuff over there and
outkick.com and enjoy mexico
get have a couple margaritas in the
freezer good work yourself i'm proud of
what you're doing and what you're
building and happy to be a part of it as
well thanks for letting us ride on good
seeing you man
good to see you as well if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell